Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
installments of this class
until the month is completed.
in its place and in its
stead, I will be holding a
class in every night after
the
month of Ramadan inshallah.
So, these months, these classes
will be suspended until after
Ramadan and this the last class
we will be doing until after
Ramadan inshallah and during
the month of Ramadan, every day
after we will sit for about 40
or 45 minutes in the topic of
regarding the
Surah
in choosing a topic for
is a very deep subject. It's a
very important and crucial
subject. it's mostly
important for us to explain and
expound upon chapters of the
Quran that we have all
memorized. However, in order
for us to go through a
particular narrative that is of
Great pertinence to the month
of Ramadan. We have chosen
due to
the fact that we are
approaching Ramadan, we will be
as we have in the past two
classes, adding from the books
of the with regards to the
rulings and conditions and
pillars and obligations and so
forth of Ramadan in order for
us to be most possibly ready
for welcoming this great month
that is upon us.
Ramadan.
And
[Silence]
Ramadan end. When is the day of
Eid? This is an ongoing issue
with
a group of people, if not, a a
large group, a substantial
group that are confused with
regards to this issue. Many of
us have come from other
countries whether it be from
Jordan or Yemen or any of these
countries. Palestine, and many
of us fall into a kind of
conundrum when there is a
difference of opinion with
regards an internationally
different opinion with regards
to the commencing com of the
month of Ramadan, the ending of
the month of Ramadan. When
should I start fasting? When
should I end my fast? When does
the month of Ramadan come upon
us? So, many people will become
confused when they hear of the
month of Ramadan being
announced in Saudi, being
announced in Jordan, being
announced in Yemen, and it is
not announced here in America
or vice versa. And so, It's
important for us to take into
account that the month of
Ramadan commences
When the people acknowledge it
as the month of Ramadan. This
is the of Sheikh Al Islam
that the month of Ramadan does
not commence with the birth of
the crescent The month of
Ramadan commences with the
acknowledgement of the masses
of the Muslims that it has
begun. This is an important
topic. There should never be an
instance when one Muslim is
fasting and the larger mass of
his community are not or that
the larger mass of his
community are fasting and he is
not or that he begins his day
of Eid and not fasting whilst
the mass majority of his
community are still fasting and
and so forth. This is
incorrect. and the correct
opinion is that every place has
its own community and when that
when that major group or the
the majority of that community
acknowledges that the month of
Ramadan is on this day and they
begin to fast, we fast with
them.
Islam
And a
[Silence]
that the prophet said
Fasting is when you all fast.
And breaking the fast is when
you all break your fast. And
Abha, the day of Abha, is the
day when you all sacrifice. The
day of sacrifice is when you
all sacrifice. What does this
narration mean? This narration
means that a person is going to
fast with the majority of his
community. and a person is
going to break his fast when
the majority of his community
break their fast. And a person
is going to celebrate the day
of when the majority of the
people celebrate the day of
Alha. It is incorrect for a
person to fast with another
community. And be the odd one
in his own community. This
defeats largely a great or one
of the greater purposes of
fasting altogether in the same
month.
If a person were to fast we
know that. We can fast and make
up days of Ramadan that we
miss. We can make those days up
any days throughout the year.
Correct? Any day throughout the
year, we can make up those
days. And so, we understand
from this that what is intended
by fasting is the amount of
days not necessarily, the
length of the days. Ramadan can
come in the winter. It can come
in the summer. A person can.
Could have missed a day of
Ramadan. During the longest
days of the year. And fast and
make up that day during the
shortest days of the year. And
it will be valid. So, when
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
death, he says, fasting has
been prescribed upon you all as
it has upon those who have
preceded you in order that you
may attain. Tuckwa and
righteousness and a fixed
amount of days. A fixed amount
of days. The scholars of Tafsir
tell us that this wording, a
fixed amount of days,
articulate that what is
intended is the amount of days
and not necessarily the length
of those days. So, if a person
misses a day of Ramadan when
they should be fasting 12 hours
and then they make that day up
with a day that is short and
only fast for eight hours or 7
hours, that is a valid fast and
it takes the day. So, if we
look at it from this angle, we
could see that why was month of
Ramadan specified. Obviously
was specified for a number of
reasons but why specifically
this month? In order that all
of the Muslims fast together
and break their fast together.
Otherwise, we could be told,
fast 30 days throughout the
year. Just fast 30 days
throughout the year and people
will fast as they choose. But
this is not how it was
obligated. It was obligated
during a specific month in
order for all of us to fast
together. And so if we
Understand this and then we
start to fast with people that
are not in our community. So,
we have a guy fasting and
another person not fasting.
This defeats one of the greater
purposes of fasting the month
of Ramadan. Does this make
sense?
No, there's no time limit. The
opinion of the majority of the
is that a person may fast any
makeup day of Ramadan during
any time of the year.
Al
Ramadan.
[Silence]
they don't have to. Fast those
days of Ramadan immediately
after Ramadan. There's no
limit. The only limit is the
next Ramadan. So you have to
have made those days up before.
next year's Ramadan approaches.
Otherwise, you can fast any day
throughout those days. But the
point here is that if we hear
of you know, one of these major
Muslim countries Saudi
Arabia is announced that today
is the first day of Ramadan or
tomorrow is the first day of
Ramadan and that is not the
case in our community here, in
our area, then we would not
fast with we would fast with
our community and likewise, we
would fast with our, we would
break our fast with our
community and so it's very very
important that we understand
this, wisdom behind fasting the
month of Ramadan and when we
break our fast. There shouldn't
be a situation where a person
is fasting Ramadan and the
person next to him is not
fasting. Or one person is
having Eid and the next person
is not having Eid. And we hear
about this sometimes. Al that
is largely largely taken care
of here in this community.
There's been a there's been an
agreement amongst the majority
of the Masajid here in Chicago
including this masjid that we
all fast together and we all
break our fast together.
Alhamdulillah. However, this is
an important issue for us to
take into into consideration.
That's we fast when the
majority of our community fast
and we break our fast when the
majority of our community
breaks its fast. We do not fast
alone. We do not break our fast
alone. And this resolves a lot
of issues that come up. Not
just issues of who's fasting
and who's not fasting. I've
seen instances where people in
the same house. Some of them
are fasting and some of them
are having eat. And the same
day. Right? And I've seen
instances where some people are
still not fasting and the other
people have begun Ramadan. In
the same house. Let alone in
the same Masjid or in the same
area. This is something which
is incorrect and when we have
issues that come up such as the
day of Eid is a day off for the
kids at school. So, the schools
will, you know, the government
will make it a public holiday
or a holiday for the Muslims
for the commencement of
Ramadan. So, when is Ramadan?
Well, we don't know. We have to
tell you a day before. When is
the end of Ramadan? We we have
to wait and see and so we have
some kids that are going for
Eid, some kids who are not
going for Eid and so, This is
largely problematic and it's
something that should be taken
into account. When you live in
a community, you attend a
masjid, you are in an area, you
fast with the people of that
area, irrespective of what is
happening. elsewhere. There is
a narration in Sahih Muslim in
which Abdullah have been Abbas,
arrived to Hashem where
was and the people in Medina
had began fasting a particular
day while the people in Hashem
had not began fasting yet and
Ibn Abbas said,
Solomon.
[Silence]
or turkey or wherever people
go. If you are going to Ohio,
you will fast and break your
fast with the people there. The
point is, is that everyone
should be on the same page when
they are together. This is what
is important. We mention the
pillars of fast we said there
are two pillars to fasting. The
first is
[Silence]
of the prophet in that
There is another issue and that
is, what if a person is unaware
that tomorrow is fasting, that
tomorrow is the beginning of
Ramadan. And so, the person
wakes up, they're going through
their day, and then they
realize that this is the month
of Ramadan. Everybody is
fasting. And so, they begin to
fast when they hear that the
month of Ramadan has begun. Do
they have to make that day up
or not?
The
[Silence]
instance, a person goes to bed,
they are unaware that tomorrow
is fasting, right? So, they go
to bed and they, you know,
don't don't know that tomorrow
is the day of fasting. They
wake up, they go through their
routine, they eat breakfast,
whatever it is and and eight,
nine o'clock in the in the
morning, they realize that
today is actually the first day
of Ramadan. Does this person
have to make up that day or
not? It's a difference of
opinion amongst the scholars of
Islam. The opinion which was
bolstered and chosen and
adopted by Sheikh Al Islam. Ibn
Tami, Rahim is that the person
does not have to make that day
up. Rather, the person is to
begin his fasting immediately
as he knows to cease from
anything that will break his
fast, to hold the intention,
and the person will have day
considered as a valid day of
fasting. They do not have to
make that day up.
Another thing that comes up and
here we are kind of tying up
loose ends. We've discussed a
lot of the basics of fasting.
We're just tying up some loose
ends to kind of prepare
ourselves for the coming month.
Masa Allah. With A Ida Canal in
San
[Silence]
having her menstrual cycle and
at around time, her
menstruation ceases. Does she
have to begin fasting for the
rest of the day? Or can she
break her fast for the rest of
the day? The correct opinion
the opinion of many of the
companions have been amongst
them. Ibn Masud, who said,
whoever has broken his fast at
the beginning of the day, then
he is permitted to break his
fast at its end. And what this
means is that if a person is
travelling for instance, and
they arrive home in the middle
of the day, and they had broken
their fast in the morning, they
had a, they had a permission,
an allowance from Allah to
break their fast at the
beginning. Do they have to
begin fasting until the end of
the day, or can they continue
to eat and drink whatever they
until the next day, the
the correct opinion is that
they not have to begin fasting.
They can break their fast at
the end of the day just as they
did in the beginning because
they had a legitimate excuse. A
permissible. They have done
something permissible at the
beginning of the day and they
have to make this day up. So,
the rest of the day, they can
break their fast as well. This
happens often as we mentioned,
someone who is traveling,
someone who is ill, someone who
has to take some medicine,
let's say a person has to take
some medicine at nine or ten
o'clock. They have some
doctor's appointment. They
can't push it to outside of
Ramadan. They go to it. They
are given some kind of
something that will break their
fast. Do they have to? Fast for
the rest of the day? No. They
break their fast and they can
continue to break their fast
throughout the day. However,
Lakin
in
[Silence]
A. Does this person, can this
person, if they broke their
fast unrightfully at the
beginning of the day, continue
to break their fast throughout
the day? No, this person must
begin to fast immediately and
repent to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. But if a person has a
legitimate excuse such as
illness or travel or any of the
excuses that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has mentioned. This
person does not have to fast
throughout the day. They may
break their fast and maintain
the breaking of their fast even
if that illness or that travel
has ceased.
Yes, they have to make that day
up because they had a
legitimate excuse to break
their fast that day. They make
that day up later but a person
who does not have an excuse and
breaks his fast, he must fast
for the rest of his day and he
must make that day up as well.
Now,
[Silence]
the
Pence for that fast that she
has missed. Should she merely
make those days up? Or should
she
should she pay the the or
should she pay the and make
those days up? These are three
opinions of the scholars of the
Correct opinion is that a woman
who breaks her fast due to
pregnancy or breastfeeding She
merely makes those days up. She
breaks her fast during the
month of Ramadan due to
breastfeeding or due to being
pregnant. She merely makes
those days up. When does she
not make those days up? She
will not make those days up if
she starts to accumulate more
than one year's worth of
fasting. So, for instance, a
woman is pregnant during
Ramadan and then after Ramadan,
she has her baby and now she's
going to breastfeed and so she
breastfeeds now for 2 years.
She misses another Ramadan and
then she gets pregnant again
and so forth. She goes into
this kind of cycle. A woman may
end up with seven or eight
years worth of fasting, 7
months, 6 months. This woman
will not make up fasting in
this case. Merely, she woke she
will pay which is to feed a
poor person for everyday which
she missed. And this is the of
many of the companions. Such as
Abdullah Ibn Omar and Abu
Huraira and Abdullah. As was
mentioned by and others. And
these companions
terminally ill. The terminally
ill. Someone who has an illness
that they are not expecting
this illness to go away. Or
this is an illness which will
last three or 4 years. This
person does not make those days
up. This person merely pays the
Kafara or pays the pays the and
so a woman who has this issue.
She's not ill. She's not
terminally ill. However, she
has the same situation a person
who is terminally ill. So, she
will take the same ruling As
these companions and others
have have mentioned.
In closing,
and